can you see what's happening it's live
in new auckland in new zealand they're
just about to start i don't want to
speak over their countdown because it's
the first one of 2021 so let's have a
listen
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so there you have it uh new year
it's a bit of a damp one isn't it um
but i suppose at least they did have
something
so many cities around the world
calling off their celebrations
completely but new zealand um there's
auckland the sky tower there and um
obviously successful in keeping the
virus at bay
and auckland
opened up restrictions this week so
people could celebrate a bit a bit so
there they are there you go in new
zealand it's 20 20 20 20 22.